バンカラジオン私の名前は最強の母親きこ
今日も特売品がいっぱい変えて幸せだちお
ほらドラボンち
なさいドラボン
チズえまだけるじゃないかああの貧乏ば
なんで持ってるのにあんなもしてん
ね
おい大丈夫か大丈夫かおい大変だ誰か大
医者さんなんだなん
だだめだもう助から
ない見つけた
わよくもやってくれたわね
あこれで死んだ
か行きかった
え目の前にいる困ってる人を助けるこれは
栄養現場だけじゃなく人として正しい行動
だあはい今日から遅機構を医者に任命
する今ならよろしくねこうして私は医者に
なったのだっ
[音楽]
たまずは診察から患者さんの声をよく聞い
て病気の原因を突き止めるのそんなこと
言われてもわかんないわ
よミクりさん診察失どうぞ
[音楽]
はいほら患者さん来たわ
今日はどうされましたか最近なんかお腹に
違和感があって何か変わったもの食べまし
たか特にはちょっとレトゲ取ってみ
ましょう
[音楽]
か大変体の中に巨大な耳が入ってるわ
おそらく体内にあった大量の耳が変異して
巨大の耳になったのね今すぐ緊急手術を
あんた希望すぎる
でしょ
うおあ取れたわでかありがてえ
[音楽]
えはい今月の
休業
うわあそれとボーナスこれはきこ先生が
助けれそうの数にをして増えていくから
ねか稼ぐぞ
[音楽]
お金が大量だ
ちょお母さんそんなに稼いでるなら俺にも
スイッチ買ってよ絶対やよ私が汗水流して
稼いた金をじゃあせめてご飯台だけでもや
です自分で稼ぐ方でも考えたら
[音楽]
ち
プロテインシャンパンもう1本はいこれ
はいシャンパンプロテインいただきまし
た大大金
大
キキキ
キキキ筋肉じゃなくてカやない
かい
きこちゃんもう1本入れてよあでもお金
なくなっちゃったら稼からまた
ねまにまにまにまに
ボロ儲け
はあな何よこれ患者が1人もいないじゃ
ないの患者がいないのは平和な証拠です
ねくそこれじゃ全く稼げないわちょっと
待って
なさい相対
[音楽]
成功今日の給食はカレー
です
ちょっとスパイス入れ忘れちゃったので
こちらを
召し上がれそれで
はいただきますいただき
[音楽]
ますはいおい
おい勝負よ頑張ってこい
うわ
う
うててててててて
うわ
う
[拍手]
[音楽]
マニさあて稼ぐわ
よちょっと痛いけど我慢して
ね
はい
[拍手]
った
ウよよいしょ
よいしょ
よいしょ治ったっ
た大事にキリト先生
あと
[拍手]
あ今月の給料とボーナスだよく働いてくれ
た
ねこれからもっと仕事が増えるよ頑張り
ます
[音楽]
やいらっしゃい
マ今日はたくさんお金持ってきたから
マッスルシャンパン3本はいはいマル
シャンパン3本いただきました
お大金大金
大金緊急です手術をするので今すぐ病院来
てください緊急って今遊んでるとこなのよ
緊急なんです来てくださいああもう大近大
大金これとこれとこれかなキネちゃん手術
が成功したらスイッチ買ってあげるから
少し手伝って本当約束だよ頼んだわよ
うん
メス
[音楽]
おす押す
よし押すよイケメンの押すよしなさいよ
はい持ってきました
あら動めちゃんじゃない
[音楽]
の
リラックス先生がってるふざけてる場合
じゃ分かってるわ
よ屋根ちゃんこれはどうすればいい
のこれは生血症のの中で黒んでる部分が
あるはずだからそれを見つけてきるん
だあっ
た間安定しました手成功
[音楽]
ですミ
ワミお母さん約束通りスイッチ買ってよえ
何の話
かしら
ティティおい焼きと違うじゃん
かはい緊急です今すぐ来てくださいまた
分かったわ
よ大体そんな稼いでも使う時間なかったら
意味ないでしょどんな状況でも稼いだやつ
が正義なの
よ
家族の時間はお金では買えない
[音楽]
よあんたまたダなの
ねしっかり捕まってなさい
[音楽]
あイケメンちゃっちゃうわ
よ
[音楽]
きこ先生研究です今すぐ来てください疲れ
すぎて私も働けないわ息子の根さんが遺跡
不明の渋滞で運ばれましたなでっ
ては何なのの水不足と栄養出張による突然
の然です姉ちゃん私がいなかったからご飯
も食べれなかった安心してけなかったのね
今から頑張るちゃん待っててちゃんてって
[音楽]
くださいやるちゃん必ず助けてあげるから
ねメ
[音楽]
はいメスって言ってるじゃないのこれない
な
ういや俺の扱いす
やろ
それどこどう切ればいいんだっけそれを
突き止めるのがる先生のお仕事
でしょ
えい
役が止まりましたあ多分切るとこ間違えた
わ
あきこ先生時間がありませ
んこうなっ
たら私の強力な遺伝子が入ったこの血を
輸血すれ
ば
[音楽]
お願いこれで回復し
て良かっ
た
[音楽]
ああはややれ
ちゃん
やちゃん行け行け行け行け
けけけ元気になったのねおかげ様でね
よかったわそれじゃ帰ろっか
えきこ先生どこにもう十分稼いだしこの
仕事やめるわえ
バイビー久しぶりの家
だもぱしにし
ててかこんなにゲームってあったかしら
え金庫のお金がないじゃない稼いだやつが
正義ってお母さんが言ってたからそのお金
俺がもらっておいた
よお母さんが金庫を隠してる場所実は
こっそり覗いてたん
[音楽]
だ
いろんなゲーム機を買って遊んでたらつい
楽しくなっちゃって気づいたら1週間も寝
ないで過ごしてたよけけけけけけそしたら
く眠するとこだったけど
ねたまた病院よりにろか
ちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録